hello and welcome to this video
here i'm black against hey chess poker
okay
somebody that i know no ah
the good old russell nemo yeah yeah yeah
okay let's play something
serious not h5
i think i do this right
okay probably h6m that has to be played
anyway in some point
at some point and um
make sure that no knight g5 business is
annoying
b4 is the way to go normally in those
positions
and black is
not really
willing to take that pawn and give white
this huge compensation with the open
files like
you take twice on before and then bishop
a3 and
things like that so i'm happy to simply
keep my botvinnik pawn center here
and um claim that the structure is
fine for me interesting
so c takes
is ready well this is an interesting
decision
if i take with the e pawn
and probably yeah he has for f5 then but
that will happen anyway the question is
how do
we go about it
yeah i will i'd like to have this
counter play against the c pawn actually
so it should be six
i don't think he will take but it's a
reasonable pre-move to enter
and maybe he will take actually
a pawn to d5 is not
such a great prospect if you think about
it
it still does does that okay
so if i take with the knight on d5
pawn will take i guess
interesting um i'm going to take with
this actually
i have a different idm
knight f5 is my idea
basically saying that this bishop now is
a is a tall
pawn and i'm trying to exploit the dark
squares
knight d6 maybe knight d6
there was a second idea the knight is
nicely placed here
do i play e4 here e4
that is probably an opportunity that i
should not
miss cannot take as the knight then
grabs the bishop
and i have knight take c4d3 coming
like breaking through in the center
quite forcefully
where is the queen actually going this
is an interesting question
to g3 i guess or um
to h3 um
if i'm
okay move first think later
um if i play e3 here right
is that maybe a thing
rook c8 is also good for black
but e3 is kind of it's almost killing
off this bishop
a3
i'm not sure this is also a good move
i'm just attacking the pawn and there's
no way really to cover that
and that i thought i can just i can just
sacrifice
this one yeah yeah i can just sacrifice
that
come on
queen takes d5 coming and that is a
completely dominating position
everything is covered and he's got
nothing really
um nothing special
to stop that pawn um
avalanche in the center so this
yeah i have to be fast here of course
f5
[Music]
piece d3
f7 is is attacked so
[Music]
maybe this is too slow i don't know
the time is uh as usual not my
friend let's say i took a bit long
as i often do
94 ah
no or do i have something crazy there
maybe i had okay let's cover that pawn
make sure that it's not dropping quickly
okay
slow move but
how do we do this this one queen trade
yeah okay
this is this is winning easily
um
jesus
making my life difficult
and look here right
let's check this a little bit
so we got this position
and he went f4 which is
a sharp decision but i think that should
be good for black right
this knight f5 thing yeah
at least the engine agrees on first
first sight
takes takes queen f3 knight d6 that
looks really good
and then he he allowed this e4 push
yeah that's excellent yeah and here rook
takes is also the best
move so i i did okay here it was a
was okay um but i'm
probably dropping the ball somewhere
here
with uh yeah this is a bit passive but
i couldn't quite play this
it just looked uh very loose queen g3
i made two blunders it seems at the end
some somewhere it's it's possible of
course with no time
but okay my move rook c7 was not really
spoiling anything
yeah e3 of course yeah he had rook takes
d4 he had rook takes d4 i missed that
it's really um yeah
it's pretty bad
h5 is a good one by the comp just
pushing the queen away
and there are many moves that that win
here of course
yeah e3 um if he takes
i was thinking i don't have that yeah
i'm bishop
this looks fun but it doesn't quite work
yeah because he can take this bishop so
other than that it would win yeah oh
yeah mine okay that's a
big other than that
so yeah i would probably i would have
lost
if he takes
with no no time on the clock i probably
would have fumbled him
yeah so that is um basically making
yeah so it's a bit of a pain because the
the game otherwise was
was nice okay guys thanks for watching